this episode brought to you by Stardust
fan sharing video reactions to movies TV
and trailers also brought to you by
honey always applying the best coupon
code at checkout they have your back
[Applause]
remember it so you don't have to we're
all aware of the Muppet Christmas Carol
with Michael Caine as seen in this clip
what I often see in television or cinema
is people who are looking at someone
else and they change eyes just on
changing eyes and I'm blinking yes I see
it's very realistic to the worst things
to do well you never change eyes you
pick an eye now which I do you pick
point just like oh I look with this eye
and if I keep blinking it weakens me and
I just keep going and I don't blink and
I keep on going and I don't blink you
start to listen well I'm listening
because I'm wondering why you're not
blinking I wish I could blink but your
definition I should be the greatest
actor in the world as opposed to someone
who is sitting there going even blinks
like that you have to concentrate to
blink like that Merry Christmas
oh it's fine for what it is it is a
shame that not a lot of people are aware
of the Muppet family Christmas special
[Music]
airing on TV in 1987 the special was
released on VHS but sadly never on DVD
or blu-ray where the reason maybe that's
the biggest gathering of all the Jim
Henson characters with the Muppets
Sesame Street Fraggle Rock even the
Muppet Babies make it in there somehow
but sadly with copyrights being bought
and sold among the properties they never
came together to sort out a digital
release and I'm here to ask should they
is this something we deserve to see Pass
YouTube and busted VCRs if everyone came
together to push crumpets and tea why
can't everyone come together for this
well I'm gonna quickly look over this
holiday special to see if it's worth it
this is the Muppet family Christmas it
starts off with the gang singing the
only Christmas song legally allowed to
be played as a polka
actually it's snowing many a flurry and
you should be driving slower it looks
like the driving up to give Fozzie's
mother a surprise Christmas visit which
is a shame because she apparently had
other plans
okay is waka waka two bears what Shalom
is two Jewish people
it looks like doc the owner of the house
the Fraggles live in is renting the
house while Fozzie's mom is out are you
my landlady oh no schmuck I didn't know
I was renting from a bear oh did a bear
to your family actually it's totally
possible but still whoa now who could
that be anyone getting a feeling this is
an older version of window from Bob's
Burgers oh he doesn't get drunk she just
has fun but Fozzie brings the merriment
much to his mom's surprise Oh hide your
genitals I read the news you promised me
okay she's taking all of this much
better than she should be I would still
half a ton two lamb chop sing-along but
Miss Piggy calls and says she'll be
showing up late she leads a photo
session I just scheduled okay now give
me more over the shoulder honey hold it
this photographer says he wants these
first personal collection I'm not even
kidding listen to this guy oh yeah
couldn't be nicer Oh beautiful oh oh oh
no do that pouty thing
oh don't judge me were all animal and
even more kooky characters seem to keep
popping up Swedish Chef Wow that's what
his friends even called him Swedish Chef
Swedish Chef but it looks like he
invited a turkey too and gonzo tries to
save him from ARMA gobble game don't you
realize it could be very dangerous for
turkeys around here not to worry I'm a
survivor
I'll survive like all the other famous
turkeys like oh my god there aren't any
did anyone see free birds please tell me
you saw free birds my life depends on it
Kermit meanwhile has a relaxing chat
with his nephew Robin we always come
together at Christmas yeah wife we just
pass in a blur for work for times like
this you know there was a reason you
were replaced by orange you but the band
liven things up by singing Jingle Bell
Rock yeah there's no point to it by shut
up Pepe the Frog stool sample meanwhile
Fozzie makes us no man outside while
ruff plays inside I refer you to my last
joke literal fire mean well the Swedish
Chef tries to cook the dog that old
Swedish stereotype he is not a Christmas
turkey years after that they find some
old home movies of their first Muppet
Christmas together
ah
[Music]
the last known footage of Skeeter before
she went to join Avenue Q I told you we
don't talk about her anymore sorry
anyway we all know this isn't the
earliest Muppet Christmas get-together
it goes back ages ago again from the
Muppet Christmas Carol if you're fair
and you've got blonde eyelashes like I
have did you just call yourself fair you
wear mascara because if you have blonde
eyelashes and you're in a movie you must
have been a radio play some more of a
makeup Department issue isn't it and
what does it matter if you're not gonna
blink they're not gonna see it anyway
I'm afraid of you
hey everybody is time to see Stardust
apps best reactions to this special here
are the runners-up I wish I could do it
better but now there was so many muffins
so many freaking Fraggles so many
freaking Sesame Street character I like
to do pretty good thanks again to
Stardust gap it allows you instantly to
film your reactions to movies TV shows
and even trailers happy angry confused
whatever it is and whatever your
reaction is Stardust is there to show it
some of the wildest and craziest
reactions are on there and there's so
much fun to watch there's a lot of
variety endless possibilities and
they're definitely worth checking out
we'll show you the best reaction to this
special at the end also stay tuned
afterwards to see how you can beam the
next nostalgic
I hate coupons actually that's not true
they save me money but I hate looking
for them why can't they already be
applied to whatever product you're
buying honey I'll tell them honey honey
honey is a free browser extension that
saves you time and money when you shop
online it instantly finds every working
coupon code on the Internet it
automatically applies the best discount
to your card at checkout which means you
always get the best prices on Amazon you
can even track the price of any item so
it can notify you if it drops it's super
fast super free and literally only takes
two clicks to join just go to this
address
add it to your browser and as Time
magazine said it's basically free money
so just because Black Friday and Cyber
Monday are over doesn't mean you can't
save a ton of cash on last-minute gifts
in fact they saved over hundreds of
millions of dollars for over 6 million
members
that's an average of 34 dollars a month
saved there so dedicated to finding the
best coupons they test over a million
codes per month just to find you the
best ones they've partnered with eBay
New Age ecru Walmart Expedia and that's
just a name of you there's no reason not
to join this free it saves you money and
again it only takes two clicks just go
to the link below and start saving this
holiday season start at join honeycomb
slash nostalgia that's join honeycomb
slash nostalgia
[Music]
[Applause]
so what looks like the turkey is putting
the moves on Gonzo's feathery girlfriend
who is my girlfriend you've gotta be
kidding
you're not even a bird let's just say
the Attic matches the basement okay but
before feathers fly the Sesame Street
gang pop by to sing carols not with this
hand though with faulty falala lalala
lalala sang be joyous all together Big
Bird should be dead in this weather did
you know the dark starts with the letter
D why yes yes yes starts with the letter
why'd true and true starts with the
letter D what is this where we come from
this is small talk why you come back to
me that joke was perfect just when looks
like the chef found his turkey the
turkey introduces him to an even bigger
delicious helping well looks like the
storm is getting worse and Miss Piggy
still hasn't shown up
Foley's mom still tries to figure out
where to put everybody I'm assuming they
share a bed
speaking of which they act out their
highly prepared Sesame Street pageant
next come on up Bert
I won't come on 5z and kermit are over
there and we all know we're doing their
voices
Ernie why must you always humiliate me
come on Bert somebody has to play mama
our female cast is limited and we still
don't know what sex elmo is but I heard
him exclaim ere he drove out of sight
this has been a two-headed boar at
Christmas everybody
then Fozzie wants to show Kermit his new
comedy partner the Snowman he made
earlier hey hey hey everybody would you
like to see I new act just as long as
you're not giving a 20min short before a
Pixar film you'll be tolerated but they
got some not so friendly friends to
perform in front of Christmas and seeing
how this Christmas I was gonna be out of
town I'm gonna check and see if I have
Alzheimer's
hey Fozzie yes mr. snowman you're here
about that church that burned down Holy
Smoke
Oh your people burned to death okay what
if I keep it cynical put a beat they boo
them off the stair as the Swedish Chef
tries to knock out his meal but keeps
getting knocked out himself but Big Bird
gives him a gift reminding him of how
difficult it must be to be away from his
home in Sweden tell me exactly what are
you going to fix for Christmas dinner
for vehicle credit my absolute favorite
as the storm gets worse Miss Piggy tries
harder to get there while Kermit worries
doc having befriended them though
decides to go look for her watch your
friend look black oh well to begin with
her
she's a pink well up to a short while
ago I would have thought that strange I
mean I have problems with women too but
I never call him that
funny enough as he leaves the house
Robin discovers a Fraggle hole in the
basement beautiful oh no you took a
wrong turn now you're in Dark Crystal
look out they'll result in mixed
opinions they of course come across the
Fraggles sneaking through the tunnels
well actually
came down here to wish you all a Merry
Christmas oh don't you have Christmas no
have none of you seem a he-man shear a
Christmas special you wish each other
peace on earth we have a time like
pebbles been a gift 37 times forget it
I'm not saying happy holidays your
celebration exists not it looks like doc
not only found Miss Piggy but he used a
bunch of sled dogs to get her home
suddenly there was Miss Piggy with this
costume for me
well I've concerning questions about all
of this well now that everyone is
finally together they sing happy holiday
[Music]
how long is the rest of this
yeah the rest is literally singing folks
don't get me wrong though this is
exactly how a special like this should
end
Muppets singing doc comes in dressed as
Santa even the big JH himself making a
rare appearance I tell you what
somebody's gonna do something about
these dishes sprocket one all washing
you dry okay it warms the friggin heart
see that's the kind of special it is
though it's not really story based it's
just a warm location for characters to
drop by with season's greetings like a
lot of holiday specials that aired this
isn't supposed to be a cinematic
three-act structure like I said before
we have the Muppet Christmas Carol for
that the camera is like somebody who
loves you deeply I mean you definitely
think it loves you deeply it's the most
incredible of mistresses or lovers
whichever sexual but cameras my lover
now it will love you forever in spite of
the fact you ignore it like I'm trying
to do to you don't look at him that way
this guy's nuts
what the family Christmas is delightful
from beginning to end as long as you
know what you're getting going in it's a
warm and fuzzy special that relies more
on atmosphere and friendliness than
laugh-out-loud moments though they
certainly have a few of those too
it's meant to be head-on at a family
get-together with kids running around
and adults talking and looking at the TV
once in a while going man that's
Christmas sadly like I said though a lot
of families can't do that because it
never got a DVD or blu-ray release
however you can sign a petition to make
it happen
yep you can go to change.org and add
your name to the list will it finally
make it happen
who knows whatever the result we have a
charming special on VHS and YouTube we
can still watch every holiday it's a
good one to check out so don't miss it
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I've ever met
so bloody fast
Wow Michael Caine you look exactly how
you do on film thank you but I do not
appreciate how you a treat my ability to
teach acting Ted oh so without me
nothing personal it's just you're very
easy to make fun of feel kind of make
fun of me now if I don't the right way
let me teach you okay well if that way
okay yeah what what it's your lover
but your mother what's that's my mother
you at the same time why that what'd you
do huh it's never bleep why would I
never blink because they think it's me
well if I blink like that sure I thought
blinking is not good I don't think my
being a blink why why are you doing this
let's debate huh if you want to be good
at
you can't blink oh you have to make love
to your camera what I suggest you invest
may devise a toy trucks because you're
never supposed to break every yesterday
you've blinked like five times I'm gonna
be late put your head down okay we're
gonna go back to the basics you're
really scaring me
what Oh two two three three deeply oh
listen to pee but now what this involved
going to the hospital hey B basically
you go too fast effort gee alphabet age
all right Jay why are we doing the
alphabet with what and
but that was a word those weren't even
love it oh I know that goddamn alphabet
you house is helping w-why just ask a
question and see uh-huh
now you know the ABCs yeah I already
knew it next time huh don't you sing
with me
[Music]
what
here it is our favorite reaction to this
special from Stardust app there's only
one thing I can really say to you a
nostalgia critic after watching this
special from your buy your
recommendation and that is
[Music]
you want your reaction to be in the next
nostalgia critic next week we'll be
reviewing home alone to just download
the Stardust app at the link below
follow us at nostalgia critic record
your reaction and then tweet it to us
with this hashtag or use Facebook the
ones we like best will make it in the
next nostalgia critic video it's a
compilation this time so that means
we'll be doing a lot more than three I
even use it myself
this week I've reacted to the trailer to
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom Paddington
and of course the Muppet family
Christmas so download the app get out
there and show us your crazy reactions
[Music]
[Applause]
and if I keep blinking it weakens me
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out this week we are doing
Catholic Relief Services Catholic Relief
Services carries out the commitment of
the bishops of the United States to
assist the poor and vulnerable overseas
they cherish preserve and uphold the
sacredness and dignity of all human life
foster charity and justice and embody
Catholic social and moral teaching they
act to promote human development by
responding to major emergencies fighting
disease and poverty and nurturing
peaceful and just societies they work
with the local national and
international Catholic institutions and
structures as well as other
organizations to assist people on the
basis of need not creed race or
nationality if you look at their YouTube
page
or their site you can see all the people
they've helped and how you can help out
and play a big part in that
click on the link below and show your
love this holiday season
[Music]
you